الزخم العسكري الذي وعد به الغرب لا يقل
زخما عن حده المعارك في الشرق الاوكراني
اللافت اعتراف واضح وصريح من كييف بصعوبه
الوضع وتقدم روسيا في الجبهه بل وتحضير
الاخيره لهجوم المحتمل كبير محللون رجحوا
ان هجوم الروسيه القادم سيكون الاكبر منذ
بدايه الحرب وفقا لصحيفه نيويورك تايمز
الامريكيه تقرير الصحيفه الغربيه اضاف
ايضا ان موسكو قد تستعد لفتح جبهه جديده
حيث تسعى لتقدم قواتها عبر الحدود الروسيه
لاستعاده الاراضي التي طردت منها في سومي
او خاركب بشمال شرقي اوكرانيا في حين
تتاهب للصد سيما في ظل معلومات ان موسكو
تحشد نحو نصف مليون جندي على الحدود
وتكاثف قصفها قبل ان تصل الدبابات
والعربات المدرعه وانظمه الاسلحه الاخرى
الى الغرب او من الغرب الى اوكرانيا
وفي مزيد من التحشيد الروسي اعلنت موسكو
وصول الروبوت العسكري ماركر الى المعارك
في دومباس نشاهد